hi I'm Nicolas with Matt Welch this is
asked a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the paperback release at the
end of the month of the Declaration of
Independence as a new forward ins been
updated in various ways please check it
out Matt the next question comes from
Scott Ross via whatever odd sounds he
makes with his throat and hands he asked
how can I talk politics with my earnest
lefty friends without them screaming at
me since I know Scott Ross I can say
it's hopeless because it's you and
everybody wants to scream at you but
beyond that we got a lot of questions
that are actually exactly in that same
vein I would argue something that Bjorn
Lomborg argued last night at an event
that we had at the Museum of Sex in New
York which is that assume that the
people that you're talking to want the
same better world in the same better
life that you do some people might
dispute that but I don't for one and try
to say hey look you know if you really
want poor people to get richer faster
than you better be the world's biggest
free trader you better be supporting
more immigration of low-skilled labor
for Mexico you better be supporting a
panoply is that a word of policies that
help people build themselves up build
prosperity and build freedom from the
ground up I and this this cuts across
wide swath of policy arguments and in
our book that's what we're talking about
we're talking about helping people have
better public education helping people
escape these sort of traps that we have
in governing life so I would say use the
language and use the ideas about the
same goals and then just point out that
these methods are superior I also find
in a general way and this actually helps
me formulate arguments is when you ask
people what's the data or what you know
what is the proof they would need to
abandon their position so whether it's
say like with fiscal stimulus you hear a
lot of people saying no stimulus worked
and the reason it didn't work as well as
it could've is because what by
definition it wasn't big enough so we
know stimulus works so stimulus doesn't
work it's because the stimulus wasn't
big enough and ya ask okay well what
would what would make you abandon that
position and it's also good to ask
yourself that and you come up with
better arguments but I think Matt's idea
of talking about shared goals is
important as well as actually engaging
people on what they find interesting or
meaningful we're here for ask a
libertarian all day keep those questions
coming